first look at how the New York City
Police Department is plugging into a
Greener future they are launching the
nation's largest test Fleet of all
electric patrol cars it's part of the
city's effort to Electrify the bulk of
its nearly 30 000 Vehicles by 2035. the
move will reduce the city's carbon
footprint vastly reducing the roughly
100 million dollars spent on fuel each
year but to work these vehicles will
have to survive in a notoriously tough
Urban environment correspondent Chris
Van Cleave went along for the ride
yeah
the NYPD is putting an electric future
to the test rolling out the first of
nearly 200 new electric patrol cars the
largest police EV trial in the country
you definitely get a lot of glances and
people wanting to take pictures of the
new cars officer Ryan delacio has been
driving one of the new Ford Mustang Maki
Cruisers
was there any skepticism about having an
electric as a police car I think the
skepticism really was it being able to
charge and having the time to charge it
but as of as of right now we haven't had
any issue
turning the black and white or in the
case of the NYPD the blue and white
green has been a 15-year Journey the
agency started testing retrofitted
civilian hybrids in 2009 and pushed
forward to make a true hybrid police car
we were there in 2019 when they got
their first hybrid SUVs each delivers
about a 40 Improvement on fuel economy
saving 700 gallons of gas a year per
vehicle now the department is taking
civilian EVs and modifying them for
police work the NYPD has always been at
the Forefront of new technology and
these vehicles are part of that NYPD
first Deputy Commissioner Edward caban
this is the first time we have a fully
electric vehicle that's to be used for
patrol purposes and we have to test that
out we have to see if it stands up to
the rigors of Patrol we know our cops
can they do it day in and day out we
have to make sure these vehicles can
the Maki has more horsepower more torque
more advanced safety features a faster 0
to 60 time and faster braking than any
other vehicle in the NYPD Fleet
something we experienced firsthand on
the Department's test track
obstacle course all recruits have to
successfully navigate
listen I won't tell if you don't Chris
don't worry about those cones while the
nypd's pilot program is by far the
largest police departments around the
world are testing electrics from Tesla's
on patrol in Luxembourg to amaki keeping
the peace in Allegheny County
Pennsylvania where the sheriff expects
to save about 26 thousand dollars in
fuel and maintenance still Ford
anticipates a gradual transition it will
be a slower progression to Electric than
it is for you know a retail customer to
adjust to just because a vehicle is used
for a police officer in a much different
way with Fremont California police found
the change comes with a bit of a
learning curve down to six miles of
battery on the Tesla so I may lose it
here in a second in 2019 officers nearly
ran out of juice during a Pursuit
because the department forgot to charge
its Tesla one of our big concerns is are
we going to be able to keep these cars
out there on a continual basis inspector
Scott Alexa is the nypd's commander of
Fleet Services he's getting daily
feedback from officers testing the car
cars what are you seeing that you like
about the electrics where maybe is there
room for improvement overall the car
seems to be performing well our offices
are spending you know a full eight hours
in these costs on most occasions so we
definitely want to see them in a more
comfortable position and have more space
in the car to put police equipment in
the car so far officer delacio is liking
what he's seeing do you feel like this
is just as capable of a police car as
a gas powered car I do yeah I think it
drives just as good if not better in
some ways than than the gas power cars
you're convinced that this has a future
in policing I I am yes if it's managed
properly and uh gets plugged in at night
plugged in at night yes
um it can be used very effectively a
charged up test drive through the Big
Apple for CBS Saturday morning I'm Chris
Van Cleave in New York
he sounds like he needs a little more
convincing but what more torque more
horsepower more advanced safety features
but doesn't look like there's much room
in the back seat or a suspect yeah Chris
was saying some of them concerned that
there's not enough room it's not as
spacious yeah especially if you have two
a partner
with you yeah
if you get pulled over in the police
department so yes a partner in the
police thank you for that qualification
I think it's pretty nifty and it's great
that it's going to be yes helping save
on fuel and maintenance great story
there